a disembodied dark side and no flights
no tights smallville's finale had many
fans talking let's take a look at how
the Man of Steel came to be
after years of small town superheroics
Clark Kent's biggest challenge arrives
in the final season in the form of an
Intergalactic evil called Darkseid
though Darkseid has usually been a flesh
and blood being in the original DC
Comics he's portrayed on Smallville as
in almost spiritual dark force of nature
as this malignant energy he can take
over one's entire being with a person's
own personal Darkness as his Doorway to
make matters worse the finale reveals
that Darkseid has another trick up his
sleeve as his Homeworld of Apocalypse
arrives setting itself on a collision
course with Earth this coupled with his
newly secured hold over Clark's friend
and Ally Oliver Queen makes it look as
if the alien Tyrant might win after all
but this is a Superman story it couldn't
end with the villain celebrating his
victory could it darkseid's ultimate
plan is to claim Clark as his own
thankfully Clark is no longer in danger
of falling to his own darker side
earlier in season 10 Clark almost
succumbed to darkseid's influence but
was saved by his cousin Cara zorrell
realizing that he needed to let go of
his past in order to prevent Darkseid
from having a foothold in his life he
began a healthy grieving process dealing
with the loss of his adopted father
Jonathan Kent back in episode 100. sadly
what started as a good thing soon became
unhealthy starting their new life Clark
and Lois Lane decided to sell the Kent
farm and move to Metropolis to be closer
to the action Clark thinks he has to
leave Smallville in order to fulfill his
Destiny and while that's sort of true
selling his family's Homestead isn't the
answer either nevertheless Clark
eventually overcomes his guilt about
Jonathan's death keeping Darkseid from
warping his soul
of course before that Clark vows to
marry Lois but those plans almost don't
happen Lois calls off the wedding
because she's worried that she'll get in
the way of Clark superheroics but the
truth is that Superman needs his lowest
Lane after realizing that they're
stronger together Lois and Clark nearly
Tie the Knot Before Darkseid interrupts
as Clark's best man Oliver is in charge
of the wedding bands which Darkseid has
made him switch out for a gold
Kryptonite rank the only form of
kryptonite that can permanently strip
Clark of his powers recognizing this in
time long time sidekick Chloe Sullivan
stops Oliver and Clark breaks darkseid's
hold on Ollie once Oliver's soul is
restored apocalypse has nearly arrived
anyway and they're running out of time
to stop it although Lois and Clark's
nuptials are interrupted that doesn't
stop these two from sticking together
and officially tying the knot down the
line
elsewhere a Mirror Universe version of
Lionel Luther kidnaps Tess Mercer the
biological daughter of his regular
Universe counterpart to use her organs
to resurrect Lex Luthor who was killed
by Oliver two seasons prior thankfully
Tess proves more resilient than Lionel's
other victims and escapes but not before
mortally wounding Lionel as the older
Luther lies at death's door he makes a
pact with dark side giving the darkness
his soul in exchange for Lex's life as
Darkseid possesses Lionel's corpse he
resurrects Lex who remembers everything
about his past including uncovering
Clark's Kryptonian Heritage over the
course of her time on the show Tess has
slowly overcome her family history and
Trauma proving that just having Luther
blood doesn't mean you're destined for
evil
something that always made Smallville
special was the moments that Clark had
with his parents friends or love
interests in The Loft in his barn and
finale may just have the best Barn scene
yet after turning his back on Jonathan
Kent's memory earlier this season Clark
spots his father's ghost again after
acknowledging his need to hold on to
those he loves following Jonathan's
Spirit to The Loft Clark asks for help
almost uncharacteristically Jonathan
tells Clark that he and Clark's mother
Martha can't guide him any further and
that jorel or at least the Fortress of
solitude's AI version needs to take over
showing that Jonathan has grown in the
afterlife after following her son to The
Loft Martha adds you're the miracle we
prayed for
needs that same Miracle having given him
the strength he needed Martha and
Jonathan watches Clark speeds off to
save the world their mission finally
complete while searching for tests Clark
finds himself at the recently burned out
Luther Mansion where he encounters his
former best friend Lex newly restored to
life Lex admits to Clark that the world
needs him to become the hero he was
always meant to be before his death Lex
saw himself as this story's hero he
incorrectly believed that saving the
world meant killing Clark but now at the
end of Smallville Lexus made peace with
the fact that he's the villain of the
story Lex tells his former friend we
have a destiny together Clark
only on different sides nothing could be
truer and though their story hasn't been
written quite yet their rivalry would
soon become the stuff of Legends in a
way Lex's speech inspires Clark to be
that light that inspires the world out
of Darkness further reinforcing the
destiny chosen for him though Smallville
began with Clark saving Lex's life the
Boy Scout Mourns the fact that he
couldn't save his friend's soul with
nothing left to say Clark leaves the
battle between Superman and Lex Luthor
is just beginning
sorry I couldn't save you Lex
in the wake of all the craziness going
on with Lois and Clark's wedding plenty
of Smallville Stars exit for starters
after recognizing that Watchtower is
down Chloe leaves Smallville to restart
the systems and kick the not quite
Justice League into gear in case Clark
can't stop darkseid's plot after a
heartfelt goodbye between Clark and
Chloe she leaves the series in capable
hands now free from darkseid's control
Oliver Queen tracks down darkseid's
minions and dispatches them with ease
upon his victory Oliver takes to the
streets to witness the Advent of
Superman and stands in awe as Clark
Saves the Day Tess also continues the
fight just in her own way though she and
Clark don't get a final goodbye she dies
protecting him confronting her
half-brother the newly resurrected Lex
Luthor Tess uses an experimental
neurotoxin to erase his memories but she
doesn't just wipe away Clark's secret
Tess ridd's Lex of everything that's
made him who he was Lex kills Tess in
the struggle but as she passes away she
watches as Lex becomes a blank slate
witnessing Superman's appearance
alongside the rest of the world
there's one more superpower Clark must
unlock before Superman can truly appear
generally Clark learns a new superpower
almost every season While most
kryptonians are instantly granted powers
under Earth's Yellow Sun including
flights our hero always saw himself as a
human being even after he learned of his
alien Origins Clark struggled to see
himself as anything but human and that
mental block kept him from using all his
natural abilities for years of course
Jorah L might have had something to do
with it too after Darkseid sends Clark
spiraling our hero catches himself in
the air completing his final trial and
flies straight through its adversary
defeating the darkness though Darkseid
is gone apocalypse remains Clark returns
to the Fortress for aid from jorel who
finally expresses pride in Kal-El and
deems his training over in a powerful
moment Jorah L and Jonathan's ghost
present Clark with the Superman uniform
that Martha made for him honoring his
Kryptonian family crest in his adoptive
country's colors Clark's dual Heritage
is merged into one and after years of
the no flights no tights rule in
Smallville Clark Embraces both
themes regarding Destiny and embracing
one's past are woven throughout
Smallville but the most recurring theme
throughout the series is the
relationship between Father and Son and
that's just as true of the series finale
after embracing Jonathan's ghost Clark
is visited by jorel from whom he learns
that all of Smallville was a trial meant
to train him into becoming the world's
greatest hero while Jonathan has raised
Clark into an honorable hard-working man
Jorah L has fought to make cow L into a
warrior who could keep Earth from
suffering the same fate as Krypton more
than maybe any moment in the finale The
Fortress scene is what Smallville has
always been moving toward after years of
running away from jorel's plans Clark
finally understands them and Embraces
them and Smallville as his own since
accepting his calling as a hero Clark
has waited until he was ready to
publicly reveal himself now is the time
and it's here with his father's
blessings that Clark first takes flight
of Superman the Man of Steel
after Lois sneaks aboard Air Force One
to beg the president not to Nuke
apocalypse the engines fail in the plane
Falls not only does Superman save Lois
and the president but he then moves
apocalypse out of orbit breaking
darkseid's hold on the people of Earth
and inspiring them to fight back before
defeating the alien Tyrant Clark tells
Darkseid
people want to believe in something
greater
and it may be easier to hate
stronger to love it took Clark years of
wrestling through both to learn that
lesson and now Having learned it he
reveals himself as Superman so That
Others May too throughout Smallville
Clark has always kept his cards close to
his chest and while he still holds fast
to his secret identity his superhero
identity is now his primary source of
inspiration and Hope from now on Clark
Kent is just a reporter for the Daily
Planet it's the man of tomorrow's
Superman who inspires others to be
better yes Superman saves the day but
even that isn't the end since Smallville
began with the flashback it's only
fitting that it ended with the Flash
Forward while we got glimpses of Clark's
Destiny through prophecies visions and
his trip to the Future in the 200th
episode the final few moments of
Smallville gave us our best look yet
surprisingly that image comes from a
comic book that Chloe reads to her and
Oliver's young son but that's not all
it's here that all the familiar elements
of the Superman myth those fall into
place Lois and Clark at the Daily Planet
a new Jimmy Olsen by their side Perry
white yelling at Lois Lex Luthor running
for president and Metropolis again in
need of saving this sends Clark to the
roof as the iconic John Williams
Superman March gets louder in the
background while there he rips open his
shirt in classic Superman form an
obvious nod to the Christopher Reeve era
of Superman movies here Tom Welling
officially claims the torch that Reef
passed to him years prior when Reeve who
once played Dr Virgil Swann once
Smallville told Tom Welling that he
should wear the yes naturally Smallville
ends with Welling Superman Taking Flight
just as we always knew it would
whether it's the number of Smallville
fan podcasts or Tom Welling and Michael
rosenbaum's own talk Ville there's no
doubt that Smallville continues to make
an impact additionally DC Comics
published Smallville season 11 in 2012.
a comic series that continued Clark's
Adventures as Superman ushering the
Smallville story into a greater DC
Universe that included Batman Wonder
Woman and plenty more Adventures but
that's not all during the Aero vs long
anticipated crisis on infinite Earths
Tom Welling and Eric endurance returned
as the Smallville versions of Clark Kent
and Lois Lane now raising their young
girls on the Kent Farm Lois and Clark
have left their superheroics behind in
the style of the trademark Superman tale
whatever happened to the man of Tomorrow
Clark gives up his abilities for his
family following in his Father's
Footsteps not a bad ending at all
foreign